[Music]
there has been a very hot debate in the
past year over transgender rights and
some backlash in the area of women's
sports swimmer leah thomas made
headlines this month when she became the
first openly transgender person to win a
division one national title now some
women criticize her participation saying
that she had an unfair advantage growing
up as a biological male the issue is
playing out in state legislatures 11
states now have laws restricting
transgender girls from playing female
sports and this week the republican
governors of utah and indiana vetoed
similar new restrictions utah
legislators are expected to override
that veto a new three-part series
highlights what it's like to be
transgender in america right now it's
called trans youth town hall executive
producer and host raquel willis
interviews people of all ages about
their experiences in this clip the
panelists describe what trans joy means
to them
my trans joy is my art when people know
us as who we are and not what we are
trans joy for me is all about the love
and care that flows between friends
family community and me definitely doing
things i love with the people i love and
everything is just happy flowers coming
out of my heart the series will air on
logo a division of paramount raquel
willis joins us right now how you doing
good morning good morning so glad to be
here thank you for joining us now the
town hall creates this safe space for
conversations about the transgender
community
how does it feel to be part of something
like this
it feels beautiful i mean i think one of
the most amazing parts of the series is
that just kind of cut through all of the
fodder all of the rhetoric that's out
there and talk directly to trans youth
we're humanizing we're letting people
empathize with their stories
yeah i think you know this may sound
silly but i think many people need a
trans 101 class if you will raquel could
you just briefly explain exactly what it
means and tell us a little bit about
your own personal story absolutely i
mean being trans is really not
identifying with the gender i was
assigned at birth so for instance i was
assigned male at birth i am a woman and
it's been a journey for me i think we
all have struggles around gender because
there are so many expectations that
we're all kind of forced to meet and for
many of us those boxes that were put in
don't fit for us when did you realize
for yourself you said you were born a
male when did you realize that this
isn't really who i am well how did you
struggle with that yeah well i was
assigned male at birth and i really had
a lot of struggles growing up because i
never quite fit in with all the
standards that were put out there for
for boys essentially and so my mom you
know is one of my biggest supporters and
she when i told her i was trans and i
was figuring out my gender identity once
i was in college she was like oh okay
this makes a lot of sense because i've
seen your journey through along the
years
now
we hear you mention the word struggle
quite a bit and some of those struggles
we hear about in the transgender
community it's violence and tragedy
but you decided in this town hall to
bring up the words trans joy because you
wanted to show some positivity within
the community um explain what trans joy
is yeah i mean trans joy is really kind
of the backbone of our community a lot
of people don't know trans people have
been around for centuries this is not a
new phenomenon
absolutely and so now we have more
language than ever before and we know
more about our history some of these
legendary figures like marsha p johnson
sylvia rivera and so many more for
education absolutely so it's about
education it's about us communing
together and understanding that there's
something beautiful about knowing your
truth and being able to fully stand in
it you know one of the things that i
thought was so great is the panel you
have is knockout and you all cover a lot
of different topics including sports and
including health what can you tell us
about that yeah well i think one of the
things that people will hear in the news
right now obviously all the talk about
the anti-trans legislation but what does
it really mean to be a young trans
person right now and what are the things
that trans people need to access i mean
these young people are just like every
other young person they need to be able
to have access to health care to
education and to their passions whether
it's sports the arts and beyond dale
mentioned earlier leah thomas the
swimmer who just won a division
one title i believe and there are people
on both sides saying support her she can
play any sport that she wants and then
there's other people saying well um my
daughter was a daughter it was a young
lady since birth and she fought her
whole life to compete and now she's
competing with somebody who might have
an unfair advantage what are your
thoughts on that well i think we have to
understand that what makes any athlete
elite
is different across the board so there
are a lot of these ideas around looking
at certain factors of trans people's
bodies trans people's hormone levels all
those different things
but we
have to be looking at people
holistically and i think one of the more
important things for us to think about
is what about access when i think about
young black trans athletes have they had
access to all of the training that maybe
their white counterparts have been able
to so a lot of times we're also thinking
about class as well right what you what
do you want people to take away real
quick from the town hall yeah well i
want people to understand that trans
people are just like every other person
you know we're all in our lives trying
to figure out the best path forward and
we all
deserve to live our best lives we are
all trying to figure it out that is that
we appreciate you appreciate you
bringing that joy to the show this
morning raquel willis thank you so much
you can watch her town hall series on
logo we'll be right back